[Music]
last night a single bell tolled
99 times at westminster abbey once a
minute
to mark each year of the duke of
edinburgh's life
this morning flags fly at half-mast
around the world
to mourn the passing of a man that few
can remember life without
gun salutes will be fired in remembrance
around the commonwealth
at noon today we last saw prince philip
leaving hospital in london a few weeks
ago
frail pale but on his own two feet
if his imminent passing was inevitable
it came
as no less of a shock prince philip
earned the affection
of generations here in the united
kingdom
across the commonwealth and around the
world
he was the longest serving consort in
history
one of the last surviving people in this
country to have served in the second
world war
at cape matapan where he was mentioned
in dispatches
for bravery and in the invasion of
sicily
where he saved his ship by his quick
thinking
and from that conflict he took an ethic
of service
that he applied throughout the
unprecedented changes of the post-war
era
during the pandemic the duke of
edinburgh removed from his retirement
cottage in the grounds of sandringham
estate
to be in isolation with the queen
windsor castle
it was nicknamed hms bubble by staff
ironically
they probably spent more time together
this past year
than they had in a long time his death
will be felt most hard by his wife of 73
years
it's so sad i don't know how the queen
is going to cope
because he's been there for her
throughout
you've got somebody in the background
that's been supremely supportive to the
queen
and i think that's the thing that
matters
thoughts now turned to his funeral he
was not a man who would have wanted a
big fuss made
and the kobe pandemic would have
impacted the best laid plans
buckian palace has asked the public to
abide by social distancing laws
and suggested they donate to charity
rather than lay flowers
my first reaction was
to think of her majesty the queen
and to feel a deep sense of
sympathy and compassion
for her and for the whole family at the
loss of such
a gigantic figure particularly in her
own life
married for well over 70 years 73 years
prince harry who laid bare his rift with
the family during his interview with
oprah winfrey
is likely to attend his grandfather's
funeral
prince philip's legacy will be in the
charities he supported especially
the duke of edinburgh award he will also
be remembered for his service in the
royal navy
and bravery at sea during world war ii
the first sea lord
has paid tribute to him this morning his
generous spirit
his delight in all aspects of the naval
service and his deep understanding
of our values standards and ethos
made him such a close friend to the
service for over
eight decades and he will really
be deeply missed by all of us
after the longest royal marriage in
history
the queen is now alone her son and heir
prince charles
is now the man of the family prince
philip
patriarch consort and devoted husband
will leave a gap in national life that
might only be felt
now that he's gone alastair uncle sky
[Music]
news